Hey, Jen.
So good to see you.
I love that you never
make any effort at all.
What are you doing here?
This is my friend's
very real wedding.
You can't pull your crap here.
Oh, okay. Well, I see
the chit chat is over.
The answer to your extremely
rude question is that
I happen to be dating
a friend of the groom,
and he invited me.
Titania!
Hey girl, hey!
You made it.
You're so busy, though.
You have like, what?
5000 businesses?
I do.
What? No, no.
She has weaseled her way into
this wedding to mess with me.
That is so obvious.
Why does nobody else see that?
Okay, you're being
very loud.
Jen, I hear you, again.
I do. But you sound
insane right now.
Like, Titania wouldn't just
show up to my wedding, you know,
try and kill you or something.
I don't know.
I'm literally just here
to celebrate the love of Lulu
and her groom, that's all. Okay?